if you are going to do this if it's in
your heart then you need to start
calling yourself a filmmaker you got to
start calling yourself a producer I
don't care you know faking it until you
make it whatever you got to do whatever
you got to do but you need to call
yourself a
filmmaker your plan was to go into
medicine yes uh my father's plan uh for
me uh he uh you know doc Indian people
like I'm Indian uh are uh you know
doctor lawyer Engineers usually and
stuff my dad was a doctor and he had one
son myself that was intellectually
stimulated by medicine uh and so he
thought you should be a doctor and I and
I you know I got up into you know diding
a masters in neurobo and you know doing
well enough on the MCAT to be able to go
to school and I just told him I don't
want to do this I wanted to do film
instead so when you told him I don't
want to do this did you take any new
measures to get yourself into film after
that or it was a weaning off process um
I told him and he was like well if
you're going to do it you know you got
like two years to figure it out right
just do it so I got an internship uh I
wanted to do uh development I wanted to
do producing so I got an internship with
a guy named David friendley uh who
worked on the fox side had a three
picture deal and he did such movies uh
as Big Mama's House or Dr dittle uh the
Eddie Murphy one uh and um I I cut my
teeth being an intern there and then got
to be an assistant and then uh
discovered the amazing world of market
research for film which I then started
doing for 18 years years are testing
movies for a living what are your
thoughts on balancing a day job and
being an
artist I mean everyone's got to eat
right uh like that's that's the that's
the that's the toughest thing I mean I
think that if you have to have a day job
I think that you have to do some work
for your art every day if it's 10
minutes great if it's an hour be better
if it's an hour then that's that's the
best idea you have to sort of like keep
it's hard cuz like you get bogged down
in your day job and you don't think
about those times you're going to be on
set and like and and when you get to set
like how important that is like you got
to move everything out of your head in
the terms of that day job this is the
real job that you're trying to do so
many people you know uh have this
impostor syndrome where they're like you
know they don't want to call themselves
like
filmmakers but that's what you are if
you are going to do this if it's in your
heart then you need to start calling
yourself a filmmaker you got to start
calling yourself a producer I don't care
you know faking it until you make it
whatever you got to do whatever you got
to do but you need to call yourself a
filmmaker because that's if that's in
your heart and that's what you want to
do then that's what you need to do and
you need to work on it every day for at
least an hour at least an hour i' hope
um some days are worse than others you
know I get that too but like if you
really do want to succeed you have to be
persistent uh you always hear about like
you know you have these friends that are
not successful and they're doing their
day jobs and they're also doing like you
know trying to find this dream when you
find like one out of 10 friends actually
succeeds and you're like why did that
friend succeed versus like the other
friends that are sitting around La and
think they're actors but they never go
on auditions or whatever it is right
that person works really hard and
they're prepared and I'm not going to
say this fakakta like opportunity means
you
know whatever it is like
uh
you if you've worked and put the hours
in and you have something really unique
then it's going to be seen one day and
you have to make sure that you're
persistent you have to like this is what
you do this is my job this is this I I I
I earn money over here for my living
expenses but this is my job over here
that's what you have to think about it I
think when your dad said two years you
had left this master's program is it and
your dad said 2 years did you did you
feel that this immense pressure or did
you feel immense freedom I knew in my
head whatever he told me I was never
going back that's what I knew like I
mean I think the thing of it for me was
that I felt freedom for sure I felt like
a big weight had been lifted that's true
too I mean you know film is not easier
than medicine but
like it's different for sure I uh I just
knew for me I was never going back there
and I would do anything I would have to
do to try to be successful and in some
part of the industry to to show my
father that like I can make a living I'm
happy I don't want to do that anymore so
let me do this and I did um you know it
was full market research and so forth
and that was fine and you know my dad
would always kid me like you know we can
still get you in a Mexico in the
Caribbean I was like no Dad I'm happy
doing what I'm doing now and at the end
of the day I was I was very happy my my
dad passed this share and I was very
happy that he actually got to um see uh
come to set see what we were doing
filming the movie and then once we got
to uh number one on Netflix he really
did like he was just like my son's a
producer like he actually was just like
yeah it was nice that's great what are
some things that stopped you from making
that leap in the very beginning from
having a day job to film
making look I think that you everyone's
plagued by self-doubt you know they're
just like ah is this the right script no
is this the right script is this the
right script well I don't want to I
don't want to start unless it's going to
be perfect it's never going to be
perfect okay it's never going to be
perfect you're never going to have
enough money you're never going to have
enough time you're never going to have
to have it's never there never a perfect
situation I think at some point you
sorry my excuse my language just say
it and I'm gonna like now I'm going
to do this and you have a team around
you right that's the other thing too
like unless I had had like my producing
partner Shane borer we have a company
called malev films uh he also did Mark a
research for film right we both kind of
were cut from the same cloth and we
found this you know one BR script we
found many scripts but we found one BR
in particular we were like oh my gosh
this is a great script we need to like
sit and you know meet with these guys
and we met with David mmer who's an
amazing writer you know writer director
he never done a feature before but we
were like Hey we're first time producers
your first time writer director what
could go wrong a lot but um we we met
with him we liked Tim he was one part of
the puzzle right we had the script we
had the director who we thought would be
like you know the guy that could bring
it home and we had other producers that
we kind of aligned with who were more
experienced producers who were like this
can be real we can go and do this thing
we just need to have the money and
that's you know obviously a big thing
that SS people too is having the money
and we thought you know we went all over
the place looking for money we didn't
find any money because no one wants to
trust a first-time producer and
firsttime writer director that's that's
like low on people's list of wanting to
trust so we decided to bet on ourselves
you know like shanee put some money in I
mortgage an already paid off house and
even the direct writer director David
marmer put in a line share the money too
equal on footing to all of us in fact um
you know he bet on himself at the end of
the day so you know like I said you're
never going to have the time you're
never going to have the money you're
never going to have everything be
perfect but when you have at least some
of the pieces and you have now
confidence a little bit confidence
sometimes has to build like you're gonna
be there's like a lot of self-doubt but
if you can find the confidence and have
the team around you that has the
confidence too then you can go for for
and make it and you might as well
because no one's getting any younger was
going to say that and who was the first
one to put money in Shane and I we're
we're first funding it and then we were
like okay we're going to you know we
shot for 17 days initially sorry 15 days
initially uh in December 2017 and then
we needed to do re-shoot for it and so
at that point um our um writer director
David mmer helped out for that and he
also helped out cuz he wanted set
instead of uh instead of like you know
um real locations stuff so so the two of
you both took that leap together yes
yeah